dude I had an uncle in he had so much
hair on his neck he would gel it down
for the hurts because he didn't want to
shave it off because it was his hair and
it was like a thing against God you joke
down the thigh huh
oh he jealous whole neck hair down you
might want to gel the your you guys he
had a duck tail hanging out the back I
look like [ __ ] man you know but nobody
expects anything out of me that's the
best thing you don't think you sure what
people look you know people ask where's
the honey guy you know there's obviously
been weeks you look like you've been
stung by bees do I look blow this it
looks like you try to drink honey right
out the hive in a bunch of these small
[ __ ] blood you're small for sure dude
I'd be so all too [ __ ] 200 bees we're
babysitting my face all the time
bunch of bees where do you live that
route in a comb
you gotta tighten up bro you're gonna
get diabetes dude you gotta tighten up
bro you got that beasts enjoy the cool
masters dinner one know you've no other
choice coffee like the one in that
Christmas play like that one that's not
cool man Nutcracker the ranking Oh it
was like the leader of the people in
Vegas who sleep I know there's a
community underground you look like
they're the voice of the underground I
look like I run the underground air B&B
check did you kind of [ __ ] and now you
have a belt to make you official Oh
and you just have this giant [ __ ] rat
ever put in the [ __ ] admirers
don't pet the playboy that's what I'm
gonna make it is that on the back don't
pet the playboy dude well the scary part
is I start to think is this the best
imma look you know yeah I'm going
downhill me yeah another year before
people like oh [ __ ]
shops falling off like a [ __ ]
and Calas been falling apart man bless
his heart did I call the other day and
man I don't know if they're not I mean I
thought he was a Oh cake he just went to
an early movie he looked like a senior
you know it was just weird I caught him
in a glimpse and I was like oh wow if
the light hits his face right you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah it's time to get this
guy some jello you don't get this guy of
nice warm masks in some cucumber you
know well a lot of its distress I think
a lot of his skin falls off of his body
a lot it seems like because of stress I
almost you ever seen that movie death
become sir mmm will they take that that
that potion and that makes them stay
alive forever but there's body that
can't keep both so the falling apart
like they have to spray paint their skin
and [ __ ] and never seen death becomes is
it cool hell yeah it's a classic ah you
never heard of it
death becomes her but that becomes a
classic forever would be classic classic
what movie yeah
oh my god Meryl Streep oh I love Meryl
Streep dude well death becomes her one
of her biggest movies do died me too
with Meryl Streep bro if she met him on
to me not I wouldn't do it the other way
but I'd watch her jerk-off into a plant
oh right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]